She knew this one
No Debbie ocean convicted felon her brother Danny ocean more convicted felon she was present on the night of the incident oh
so oh
You want to hit a jewelry store
not exactly
diamond mine yes exactly right before
What?
The met
Three and a half weeks, and that would be hosting its annual ball, and we are going to rob it
Sixteen point five million dollars in each of your bank accounts five weeks from now. That's a lot
They've got every inch of this place covered this is most sophisticated security in the world
How long did it take you to figure all this out five years eight months and 12 days
Why do you need to do this?
Because that's what I'm good at
Okay everybody let's get started. Here we go.
Count me down three
two
one
Game on
She said
Dear God that was spectacular
Silvio cos we prepare for this
We will not be the prime suspects
Wait-wait-wait-wait-wait every time you do they have to start from surprise wait, what'd you do? I turned it on